rolling along through super bowl week in
miami joining us now on radio road
chargers running back melvin gordon
melvin welcome how are you good man
great actually charge is running back
for now
yeah free agency looming yes it is what
do you think's gonna happen when march
rolls around oh
hopefully i'm here hopefully i don't
have to wait till march uh to know where
i'm gonna be playing you wanna get
something worked out to stay with the
chargers i do i do um you know i got a
lot of guys that i'm close to
um that i i would love to be next to
them um holding that lombardi trophy um
so hopefully it's here in l.a
who's the quarterback gonna be of the
chargers in l.a you know but uh
you know it's just crazy man you know as
i learned last year um
you know it's a crazy business well and
what is the biggest specific lesson you
learned from what happened with you with
the holdout with how that all turned out
what's the takeaway that you can use to
carry forward in your uh that that you
can't um you know when it comes to
business uh
you have to take your emotions out of it
uh you know you
it's not about um
you know
them feeling you know if you know you
deserve to be here or not um
you know i've talked to tom plenty of
times and
you know he tells me you know you
deserve to get paid um it's just
sometimes it just might not be
the right situation either financially
or just
with other guys they have to pay or just
it could be something you know but
you know i just had to understand that
you have to take your emotions out um of
business and you know you got to apply
that to football into life after
obviously how much do you think that the
position you play affects
how you are valued as a football player
because it seems like running backs for
whatever reason and maybe that's about
to change but it seems like running
backs don't get the the respect the
piece of the salary cap pie that maybe
they deserve yeah yeah um
you know we we don't get the respect but
uh
it's a lot of backs out there um that's
that's changing that narrative
um
a lot a lot of backs that are changing
that so you know people can say that now
um
but i can promise you within the next
couple of years
um it'll be a different story who are
the backs that you think are helping
change the narrative um
obviously you know zeke helped um a
tremendous amount obviously the guys
with the big contracts before
uh zeke um you know me derek henry
christian mccaffrey alvin kamara
um saquon
uh
you know and it's gonna be even more
guys that that that you know help up
that market um so you know we all keep
continuing to do what we do
um you know you gotta you gotta you you
gotta respect this and bring up that
number who's the guy on the chief's
defense that you would tell a 49ers
player to look out for
tyrone matthew why
it's ball hog dog um i like frank clark
too
um me and him kind of got into it when
we played in mexico a little bit um
just football what happened what
happened uh just you know just calling
me soft and you know you just you know
some guys just talk that talk you know
you know what i mean and we just kind of
going back at it um
going after it and you know some guys
kind of talk to get under your skin or
whatever
and uh you know it kind of fired me up a
little bit but uh tyrone matthew he
don't really say too much well not to me
at least um
but he's definitely a guy that you have
to account for he's going to make plays
he's going to make you look bad and he's
a game changer man um that's definitely
a guy you got to look out for when you
see and hear philip rivers talking does
that make you more inclined to talk or
do you just kind of like ah let's do his
thing i'll let phil handle it you know
and and
but just don't put your hands on him you
know it's kind of how i feel um you say
what you want to say he said what he
want to say but
you know just don't don't be extra with
them you know don't put your hands on
them um
and we're going to be all right i mean
he's moved out of california and there's
been talk that the chargers are moving
on from him and there's so many
different ways all these teams can go
that need quarterbacks that are looking
at quarterback so many free agents talk
about tom brady playing for the chargers
hypothetical if you resign with the
chargers before free agency and then you
pick up your phone you see tom brady's
join the chargers what's your reaction
going to be
my reaction would be
man um
would be let's go but i you know i first
think uh you know
i wonder how phil feels yeah you know uh
same type of quarterback you would think
if you know we bring in a quarterback
it'd be a guy that's maybe more mobile
or something like that or just a younger
guy in general
um
[Music]
i don't i
you know i'm not against bringing brady
in you know i definitely want to stay
that um you know
james white is one of my close friends
and he said nothing but great things
about brady obviously um and that's just
inside locker room talk um but
you know they're around the same age i i
just i wouldn't understand that move
honestly um same style of quarterback
pocket passer yeah right and we've seen
so many great young mobile quarterbacks
come into the league i feel like the
teams that don't have a young mobile guy
have to be thinking at some level let's
go get a young mobile guy because it's
obvious they can play trend right now
you know a guy that can kind of move out
the pocket escape a little bit um but
you still got your pocket pocket pastor
guys that you know that still dominates
the game yeah um finally moving out of
that soccer stadium thank god yeah what
what
give me the idea what it's like when you
come out of the tunnel and
there's nobody there or and the people
who are there are all wearing the colors
of the other team it's not it's not the
greatest um
you know
we haven't have been able to get our
names called out um as players
offensively or defensively
since we moved to that stadium and you
know that's kind of what guys enjoy um
our families enjoy that you know it's
getting our names called out um it's
just a great feeling man you really feel
like you're part of nfl
um it's just a rush that goes through
you you know you wouldn't be able to
understand unless it's happened to you
um it's like a little rush and we don't
get that there and uh you know this new
stadium
you know we
you know i'm pretty sure we'll at least
get player intros what do you think the
team needs to do to better connect with
la because i feel like the rams had the
head start the rams have had higher
level of success they got the history in
la they were there all those years
before they moved to st louis what what
did the chargers need to do to really
connect with that fan base um i think we
need to get to that stadium um
you know get closer out there
you know playing carson which isn't la
i feel personally
um we need to get out there so people
the people of la can actually come
support us it was just crazy the amount
of people that come to
the rams game and it's because it's
actually in la um you know they they
they got that upper hand it had been
nice if we were able to play in ucla or
something like that um
somewhere out there you know but
uh you know it's in the past now uh you
know we'll be out in inglewood um so
people can come support us
celebrities can come support us
um you know we have another winning
season um i i guarantee you uh
everything will be different i i i
almost feel like you guys have been
better on the road the past couple of
years because
you never truly have a home game so when
you have to go play in somebody else's
stadium it's no big deal yeah um yeah
obviously that i think that plays a part
but um
you know i don't think we was losing at
home because uh you know
you know because of the fans or anything
like that because if you ask any player
when you're out there you really don't
notice the fans anyways it's just kind
of the start of the game and
uh you know when you actually like on
the sideline you're looking around
you're like what is going on here like
that that's the only time where you
really notice when you're out there
you're just playing football so i can't
say wins or losses are you know
determined on the fan base
um but it is good to know that you got
that support out there especially on
them third downs you know the chiefs
well you guys played the 49ers in 2018.
who do you think has the edge in the
game sunday
i'm going with the chiefs keeping it in
the afc me personally i just think
they're just too high power
uh of an offense and
you like to say well it might be a
you know
we think the offense is gonna they're
gonna run the ball they're gonna be this
exciting game and then usually when
people say that it's really a slow games
the game is really not what you think it
to be it's usually born i don't think
that's the case this year i think it's
gonna be exactly what people expect um
at least from the chiefs perspective
they're gonna score points that's what
they do that's their identity that's who
they are um
you know i think it's going to be on
jimmy
you know
demand jimmy to to to
to go pound for pound with those and and
that's what's so fascinating about this
melvin because
at some point in the second half of the
divisional game against the vikings they
just stopped throwing the football yeah
and they didn't have to throw it at all
against the packers eight passes 42 runs
i just wonder if he has to flip the
switch during the super bowl if they
can't run the ball will he be able to do
it and that's the biggest question but i
feel he will super bowl you have to you
know they're paying you all that that
money to do that to be in this situation
and
uh
to to perform
you know that's why he's getting paid
the money that he's and i think he has
the ability to do so um
i just think if it comes down to it
uh
winning the game
and patrick mahomes possession i think
he takes it yeah i agree with you he's
playing at a level now higher than
anybody else yeah he's delivered against
the texans down 24. titan's down 10 and
just keeps going all right so just to
summarize
you want to stay with the chargers yes
sir you want to get it worked out before
free agency yes you want phillip to come
back yes sir all right well we'll see
how it all plays out we know we're
getting a new stadium we hope you'll be
on the team that we do know all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports